so i believe a market crash in a
recession is around the corner and i
think it's going to be worse than what a
lot of people think is going to be and i
don't think 90 of america is ready for
let alone the world is ready for it but
those who are
are going to benefit from it the next
two to five years we'll talk about the
top 10 market crashes we've ever had the
duration how ugly was the cause of it
we're gonna talk about how to be ready
for the difference between a market
crash and a recession what other experts
are saying about it different stocks and
then anyways based on that as i make the
argument to you
at the end of it you'll be able to make
a decision what decisions you're going
to make with your finances and proper
sequencing moving forward having said
that uh at the end of it the slide is
going to be around 80 pages some of you
guys will have a way to get the 80 page
uh powerpoint that will give to you so
stick around till the very end the
reason why i did this this was a private
webinar that i hosted just a couple days
ago where tens of thousands of people
signed on and the next thing i saw is
these things were being uploaded all
over youtube
and i said i'm going to shoot this again
and i'm going to make this public due to
popular demand and then the audience is
going to be able to do whatever they
want to do with this information so
having said that let's get right into it
so first of all a couple things that
we're going to be learning today the
difference between a market crash and a
recession why recessions are important
how to prepare for them and how to make
your millions whatever the dollar amount
is for you
during and after a market crisis so
my my opinion i believe a market crash
is coming six to 24 months from now and
the only reason
i put that six to 24 is because the fed
and our politicians are trying the white
house is trying to do whatever they can
through purely fake
way of increasing interest rates or
you know a different kind of build back
better plans whatever they're going to
be doing to put money into the system to
delay
this uh market crash on the recession
that's coming midterms is around the
corner so it could be six months it
could be 12 months it could be 24 months
but it's coming recession is gonna
probably be announced a lot sooner it
could be as soon as july it could be as
soon as q4 but that's also coming here
soon but i'll give you some of the tools
i want to do to be prepared for this so
my market crash philosophy that i follow
and i'll break it down for you exactly
how this has impacted my life number one
is every time a time like this comes and
i don't believe a time like this is
going to come for another 20 to 40 years
maybe not even in my lifetime because
it the perfect storm of what's going on
today with how covet came
and we were asked to stay home but money
was sent home we printed trillions of
dollars of money and a lot of it went to
the rich some guys went from being worth
20 billion to 300 billion somewhat from
being worth a million dollars to 300
million dollars and then some of them
are going to be corrected today
and then you know at the same time the
inflation gas ukraine afghanistan there
are so many different things that are
hitting at the same time 128 month
economic expansion that we're being
affected by so
if you're ready for it this is when you
add the next zero to your net worth if
you're worth 100 grand you ought to be
worth a million dollars in the next 12
24 36 months if you're worth a million
you ought to be worth 10 million dollars
if you do it right the next two
three years if you're worth 10 grand you
ought to have a hundred thousand dollars
maybe even a million dollars but the key
is to chase the next zero your next zero
whatever that zero maybe now you may say
pat i'm only worth a hundred dollars
well then go two hundred thousand
dollars it doesn't matter what it is but
chase the next zero that's how i process
it number two is recessions are a good
thing for marketplace god knows we need
today's recession yesterday i had on the
podcast
the the gentleman who came up with the
coin the phrase quantitative easing
uh
he worked for japan bank of japan he
worked for all over the place all over
the world oxford grad all this stuff
economists and we had a debate back and
forth but i believe we need to actually
go through a recession and our
politicians need to allow this to happen
but it's actually good for the
marketplace i'll explain to you why it's
the best time to build wealth and only
the prepared where people will prevail
during this time so if you see this
picture that's me
uh i think this is day two or day three
at morgan stanley dean witter this is a
uh i got started with them a day before
9 11.
and that's my cubicle the lady in the
back she was one of my co-workers we got
hired on the same day her name is seoul
and the gentleman who hired us dave
kirby
sat us down and it was only supposed to
be one of us getting the job she was
obviously very overqualified
uc berkeley and i was under qualified
but he liked us both he gave us the job
and he said you guys got to share a
computer screen together which you don't
see us to the right she was a genius i
think she got like a 1560 on an s8 it's
our co-workers taking a picture don't
let that smile fool you nobody was
smiling because the corner stock broker
in the corner who was making 700 grand
within 12 months his income dropped to
70 grand he was not ready for it he was
golfing pretty much every day and you
know he didn't see this event coming up
and then next thing you know things
happen but dave kirby had a meeting with
us everybody was scared and he said it's
going to be the toughest time to stay in
this business this is not a good time to
stay in the business but if you do
in the next three to five years the
opportunity is going to be great for you
so the 2001.com bubble happened i got
started on 9 10. it was the worst time
to start with morgan stanley dean witter
we had 3 600 employees at world trade
center when world trade center went down
i was supposed to go to new york they
shifted our training and i went to san
francisco instead and before the next
recession while this took place this is
when i made my first hundred thousand
dollars now keep this in mind
i'm not a qualified guy i'm a military
guy without a four-year degree or a
two-year degree i'm a bodybuilder at
this time that's what i want to do i
want to be mr olympia that's my dream
and then i shifted into the financial
industry so i'm not the guy that's
supposed to make the money but i made my
first hundred thousand specifically in
savings is what i'm talking about
and then discontinued so then i open up
my own offices and insurance
this is me in a picture sitting in front
of my computer look at that earpiece by
the way those are old ones and i'm
wearing a camel hair jacket i believe
and i'm sitting there you know working
on some projects but this is 2007 2008
this picture was taken at a building
8550
uh north balboa boulevard in northridge
california right across from uh roscoe
and north and uh balboa so i'm sitting
there at this point i'm tracking
everything that's going on with the
market my savings my investments and a
few things happen at this point in this
picture i have around half a million
dollars in savings uh i started my own
insurance company a year and a half
after that october 2009 probably the
worst time to start it because this is
when aig was almost going out of
business
insurance companies at the time had
nothing to lose they had a hard time
with business and we grew it from 66
agents today we have over 20 000 agents
nationwide but before the next recession
at this time at a million dollars in
savings let me continue
this keeps going on
covid happens 2013 2014 market crash
happens in 2020. financial assistance
where a lot of people were taking ppp
loans we didn't take the ppp loan we had
a meeting with our board they said we
can get around four million dollars and
i said i'm not taking a four million
dollars i said why i said why would we
take four million dollars when we got 15
million sitting in the why would we do
that we're not going to do that let that
money be taken by other people my boy
thought i was crazy anyways years a year
and a half later at an event we had at
mgm one of our board members who's the
managing director of oak tree capital
management for one of their divisions
got up on stage in front of everybody at
mgm grand during and says hey one thing
you guys don't know is when covet hit
and we could have taken four million
dollars your ceo pat said he's not
taking four million dollars because he
doesn't want to take it so this isn't a
guy that talks capitalism he actually
believes in that stuff so a lot of
people are taking financial assistance
and i saw so many restaurants going out
of business i said they need the money i
don't need the money right now we're
going to be okay for it but the people
that need it let them be able to take
advantage of it because they're
officially being said that they're a uh
what's the word that they're not a
an essential business right these
non-essential businesses it was a tough
time to be in business of restaurants
during that time but for our business we
went from 100 being face-to-face sitting
with clients to all of a sudden i can't
see my clients because i have to do zoom
we didn't know how to do that we made a
shift immediately so when that crisis
happened i was scared i didn't know what
to do i came home after a flight we were
coming back from beverly hills hilton
had a meeting with my board de la hoya
gabriel brenner all these guys everybody
canceled because of kovit so
everything's going on with that was the
day where disney shut down you know nhl
shutdown nba shut down donovan mitchell
got coveted from rudy goldberg he was
pissed off that was the day i was in la
23 hours with the wife and three kids in
my nanny we flew back took the family to
the house i went to the office was there
to three o'clock in the morning studying
saying what the hell is a pandemic how
ugly can this thing be what can the
market react how will the market react
in nine out of ten times
the panic is so big that people panic
and then all of a sudden we recover six
months later ninety percent of the top
ten pandemics we had in the uh america
we recovered six months later the only
one we didn't recover for six months uh
12 months later was eight everything
else we recovered so i said okay we're
probably going to recover but how are we
going to sell now that i can go to
people's homes we shifted we went to
zoom 90 was zoom 10 was face to face and
then during this time because of the
adjustments we made just like some of
you guys are watching this you may be in
real estate you may be a stock broker
you may be a digital marketing guy you
may be a content creator you may be a
pharmaceutical salesperson you may run a
different you may run a restaurant you
need to make the proper pivots right now
and don't sit around being casual like a
lot of people in your industry are going
to be because the cemetery of businesses
are going to be filled the next 12 to 24
months by ceos and founders who didn't
pivot quickly they were just like yeah
it's not a big deal people are just
trying to scare us okay no problem
what am i gonna do i'm down to seven
thousand dollars in my bank account
exactly
you underestimated the severity of
what's about to happen and you're paying
a price for it and not only you you and
your 22 employees are not paying a price
for it this is why it's very important
to study material like this and make
urgent decisions quickly not sitting
there and just waiting for two years to
see what's gonna happen anyways during
this time a lot of opportunities came up
for me when people were panicking during
that time i got a call from a guy who uh
owned two wayne gretzky cars he wanted
to sell it for half a million dollars i
bought it about the two for
540 000
year later year and a half later i sold
it for 2.1 million dollars okay and
those cars took off and by the way if i
would have kept it for another year one
of the cars would have sold for three
and a half million dollars but the point
is i went from four 540 thousand dollars
to 2.1 million dollars like this easy
one and a half million dollars that was
made there that doesn't include other
investments that was made that i'm real
estate other things that i made money
the point is when people are scared
money is made because of people who have
cash and can make decisions so stay with
me here as we go through this so i went
from having six figures in savings and
net worth went from six figures to seven
figures to eight figures to nine figures
so everybody ought to be chasing the
next zero i'm chasing my next zero you
ought to be chasing your next zero
whatever that zero may be for you but
during these times scary times everybody
panicked i took a different strategy
simply because back in the days every
time i panicked i didn't make money so
i'm sharing with you some strategies
that work for me so now how concerned
should you be about the economy today
well let me share with you what a few
people are saying here's a guy named
elon musk you may have heard of this guy
he uh some call him a genius some call
him a disruptor some call him an
innovator some call him the greatest
troll in the world because he knows how
to get onto people's skins uh people's
skin under on twitter but here's what he
did say on may 26 one of the twitter
users asked them a question zack asking
do you still think we're approaching a
recession he said yes but this is
actually a good thing it has been
raining money on fools for uh far too
long some bankruptcies need to happen
also the covet stay at home stuff has
tricked
people into thinking that you don't
actually need to work hard root
awakening inbound by the way
just yesterday i want to say he tweeted
out saying and he sent the email out
that came out public
he said
you know if you want to pretend that
you're working 40 hours from home you
need to do 40 hours from the office
physical if you're thinking you're going
to do remote work at tesla you're fired
this company isn't for you he announced
that i believe two days ago it was all
over the place i can't believe he said
this remote torque is the right way to
go elon saying no remote doesn't work
you know what the following day he
announced today today while i'm
recording this today is june 3rd i want
to say it came out that tesla's firing i
believe a 10 i don't know the exact
number but they're about to let go of
some of their employees because they
have to this is the next phase that
they're going through and he lost trying
to say if you don't want to work from
home we got to let go the bottom 10
percent it's your choice so where is
elan going with this where is jamie
dimon going with this from jpmorgan
chase he said the fed only has a 33
chance to avoid a recession what so that
means there's a 66 chance we're going
into recession yep based on what jamie
dimon said uh carl icahn legendary car
like on a man many fear in the public
sector i think there very well could be
a recession even worse what do you mean
even worse this is a money guy he's
going to lose a lot of money if there's
a recession but he's probably prepared
for it
billionaire icon issues um
ominous warning why is he saying that
publicly he's in the space that it's
better for people to be thinking bullish
not bearish
leon cooperman who had on the podcast
here six seven weeks ago he's worth two
and a half billion dollars he said it's
not written in stone but that would be
my guess leon cooperman joins chorus of
billionaire investors warning of u.s
recession he sat here it's on a podcast
you can watch it i don't know what
episode it is and he said
i said how ugly will it be he said i
think we're gonna have 40 market
correction around 40 market correction
uh in 2023. i said that bad he says i
think it's going to be around 40 but he
said it in a way where yeah it's normal
it's coming soon because he's been
around the block for 40 years and he's
seen these things happen many many times
so this is not coming from somebody that
just got into business five years ago
wells fargo ceo warns u.s it's going to
be hard to avoid some kind of recession
uh this is the the
bill dudley a new york uh federal
reserve yeah federal he's the president
former federal uh president of federal
reserve on new york
very very unlikely fed can tame
inflation without sparking recession
former new york fed chief says so
we can go on and i can quote you 10
other people what people are saying but
that's not the key let's let's just get
into should we be concerned about a
market crash 75 of fortune 500 ceo said
this month that they were bracing for a
recession
let me read this to you one more time 75
percent
of fortune 500 these are the 500 biggest
companies in america said they're
bracing for a recession they said that
this month okay this is a forbes article
so now
um
it's now all about an anticipation game
what's an anticipation game you can go
and fight and all you can do is swing
okay and you're not playing defense on
all of us and you get caught and you
lose right you could get lucky and knock
somebody and watch oh my god look what a
great fighter he is but if you look at
mayweather who's undefeated his game is
what he's the anticipation game right
and then what did canelo do he kind of
learned his defensive game went to a
different level after he fought
mayweather because he realized i need to
get this defense part down everything
about business right now is to
anticipate great generals anticipate
great basketball coaches anticipate
great military leaders enter anticipate
great presidents and anticipate great
founders anticipate and you ought to
play the anticipation game what could it
look like if we have a recession today
what industries will take a hit how bad
will it be who will go out of business
who will it benefit how can i you know
put myself in a certain positioning to
benefit from this you know what what do
i need to do from now before it happens
who should i be reading what article
should i be reading where's a place
where i can get a lot of this
information out there for myself but
it's all about an anticipation game
right now so what you're doing today to
prepare what are you doing today to
prepare the more you do the preparation
now
so some say what if it doesn't happen
great if it doesn't happen
you don't buy a life insurance policy
because you're going to die tomorrow you
know we don't have a stronger military
because we're going to war tomorrow
you don't put money in the bank for
emergency fund because an emergency is
going to happen
no you're putting it because if it does
happen so if we go into recession if a
major market crash happens are you
prepared for it it's what you ought to
be asking yourself so now
recession is a period of temporary
economic decline during which trade and
industrial activity are reduced ready
generally identified by a fallen gdp in
two successive quarters
we've had one already q2 is going to be
announced july 1st if it's two
successive quarters do not be surprised
is if in july you hear some experts
saying we're officially in recession i
don't know if the white house is going
to say it because it's midterms but
don't be surprised if some economists
say
we're officially in recession okay so
now what is a market crash
a stock market crashes a sudden dramatic
decline of stocks price prices across a
major cross-section of a stock market
resulting in a significant loss of paper
wealth crashes are driven by panic
selling and underlying economic factors
they often follow speculation and
economic bubbles big difference one is a
day or a month the other one is two
quarters in a row so now
forecast
quarter one of 2022 the market economy
shrank by one and a half percent
according to the definition if this
happens again in q2 we're officially in
recession q2 ends uh june 30th this
could be the day america officially
enters a recession so what happens
during a recession companies go out of
business employees get let go borrowing
money becomes harder consumer spending
decreases stock market goes down these
are things that happened during a
recession so here's a visual
when you look at this here this is a
picture of a forest
uh it looks like it's sunny outside but
not if you're at the bottom who's
getting all the sun who's getting all
the you know love who gets the most of
the rain when it rains the big trees at
the top how about the ones at the bottom
that nobody sees you're not getting any
water you're not getting any you know
rain you're getting maybe some of it
you're barely getting any sun so it's
pretty dark right above those trees is
bright right okay
so the big trees are the big companies
that have been getting all the funding
the bailouts the dollars all that other
stuff right okay
there are a few big trees that catch all
the sun and the rain a few big companies
that hire the most best talent it's hard
for new younger companies to grow up and
compete with them kind of like what i
was just talking about until
a forest fire happens naturally
naturally
forest fires go through natural
wildfires every five to ten years
there's a phrase for this you can go
look it up okay when the natural wild
virus happens you can see the people on
the right they're scared this is a
natural cycle that we go through five to
ten years the us economic cycle have
lasted uh about five and a half years on
average since 1950s in recent years
we've closer to 10 years okay
so
when it happens this is what it looks
like right after the fire it's not
pretty it's ugly it's bleak it's dark
but very quickly it looks like this okay
and it gives opportunities for people
like yourself to make a name for
yourself this is coming this happens it
happens every about decade or so and
when it does those who are prepared for
it hopefully somebody like yourself they
flourish so now
why are recessions a good thing pad
companies go out of business room for
new companies to grow starts a decade or
so of growth and you'll see why here in
a minute no more overpriced talent
there's a lot of people in america right
now that are overpaid because
they threaten their company that if you
don't let me work remote i'm gonna go
work for another company so companies
got scared so they gave a raise i run
companies i go through these
conversations all the time
they gave the raise and after they get
so imagine the guy went from 60 grand to
80 grand then the guy that got the raise
at 80 grand his title change on linkedin
he called a few different headhunters
and he said i'm looking
and then the guy took a the resume of
the guy with the linkedin profile and he
took that eighty thousand dollars went
to different companies because the
recruiter makes twenty percent so he
doesn't care he's hoping you get a
hundred thousand dollar salary that
sixty thousand dollar person goes to
eighty thousand dollars goes to a six
figure salary with a ten thousand dollar
signing bonus that can work from home
and he thinks he's fully excited oh my
god i went from 60 to 100 000 plus 10
grand signing bonus within five six
months this happened all the time in a
market employers experienced this but
then today the market's gonna expose
that person and realize that person is
not a hundred thousand dollar person
that person is going to go back to fifty
fifty five thousand dollar your job it's
gonna happen next six twelve twenty four
months
and then he's gonna say oh my gosh you
know what's this all about but the
resume is gonna read four jobs in the
last three years and employers don't
like to hire people
with four jobs in three years they just
don't and they ask
why is this guy going from oh well let
me tell you what i'm really looking for
is to have 10 year old company oh really
yeah any reason why your last four jobs
you didn't last more than six months oh
you know one of them was this and the
other one was this yeah the market is
gonna say yeah i don't know about that
we're gonna go with somebody else
those who jumped around from places to
places to places are gonna pay price for
it so no more overpriced talent access
to talent previously unavailable there's
going to be a lot of i remember in 08
you would go on jobs.com and you're
hiring somebody there were thousands of
people with mba that are looking for
jobs who got fired thousands on top of
thousands who had mbas fully qualified
who are looking for regular jobs because
they can't find a job that's what's
going to be happening in the next 6 12
24 months again this is my opinion so
here's what's happening today inflation
hit 40-year high eight and a half
percent gas prices jumped to 48
year-over-year rental rates have
increased for eight consecutive months
the average rent for a two-bedroom home
in u.s is about two thousand dollars
according to research from rent.com up
22
from a year ago so from 1 600
to around 2 000
you may say but that's only 400 bucks
that's a car payment and insurance
that's a lot of money right there for
the average worker groceries up about 10
year over year and here's what's
happened to s p 500 just this year in
the first five months this is from june
1st to end of may let me say this one
more time this i'm sorry this from
january 1st to end of may in the first
five months so
smp is down 13.3 percent uh nasdaq is
down 23 percent apple is down
17.8
facebook is down 42 just this year
netflix is down 67
just this year amazon is down 32 percent
just this year google is down 23
tesla is down 37
just this year these are good companies
these are not bad companies some may say
they're on the stocks on sale right now
but they're down dramatically just this
year why are they down dramatically just
this year is this an indicator of what's
about to come has it hit the bottom yet
everyone's asking that question we don't
know yet bitcoin is down from uh from
whatever it was to it was forty thousand
dollars it's now twenty thousand twenty
eight it was forty seven thousand
dollars it's now twenty nine thousand
dollars bitcoin's on thirty nine percent
just this year okay i had a call with my
golden sax guys and they came and flew
out and had a meeting with me and they
said every time we increase interest
rates twice in a quarter history tells
us 60 chance we go into recession within
18 months so if they're right worst case
it's going to be end of 2023 early 2024
early earliest we can hit it could be
next month okay so that's kind of what
goldman's position is with recession but
they're saying there's going to be a
recession probably within the next 18
months so how bad will things get a few
things to keep in mind we've had a lot
of fake success the last couple years
okay there's been a lot of bitcoin
millionaires there's been a lot of
people that are flaunting money
but they don't really have a way of
making money but they everybody's like
oh my god the guy must be an expert okay
not saying bitcoin is a bad thing or
ethereum's a bad thing where stocks are
a bad thing but there's been a lot of
fake success nobody knows whose success
is real we fed so much money into the
market it's gonna go somewhere and a lot
of people got it
those who got lucky okay
will be exposed the next two three years
those who didn't get lucky will
capitalize the next two three years
we're going to learn
you know when you know when uh eminem
had his first song will the real slim
shady please stand up please stand up
will the real success stories please
stand up they're going to be standing up
the next two to three years you'll see
them and you'll know who they are and
you'll say wow i didn't know was going
to be him good for him very impressive
really interesting never thought it
would be him i thought it was going to
be him wow that guy took a massive hit
but we had a lot of fake success the
last couple years
political uncertainty uh midterms warren
ukraine not going to be pretty nobody
knows what's going to be happening
russia ukraine you know middle east you
know there's a lot of nato there's a lot
of things going on there inflation is
now looking good small businesses
haven't overcome covet and will now face
a much bigger challenge the economic
expansion after 2020 was pumped up by
fake success we have economic expansion
128 months yeah but we never really
finished it off the next crash would be
a dot-com double crash on top of the
2008
recession i'll explain to you why here
in a minute so
churchill once said the one said the
further you back you can look the
further forward you are likely to see so
the farther back you can look
the farther forward you are likely to
see so let's go back a little bit and
see what are the top 10 biggest market
crashes in the history of u.s so the
first the number 10 is what we went
through
during pandemic it was february 19th
2020 to march 23rd 2020. that's what you
call a market crash look how long it
lasted 33 days the market tanked 34 do
you remember that i clearly remember
that everybody was scared but that was
not a recession because it's not two
quarters that was just 33 days right
ninth one is computer trading from
august 25th 87 to october 1987 lasted
about two months market drop 36
dot com bubble plus 911 march 10 2000 to
october 2nd
2002 that's a recession market dropped
37 percent duration 26.8 months world
war ii crash october 39 to april 28 1942
lasted 32 months mark you dropped 38
percent panic of 1907. it lasted 11
months and the market crashed 40 percent
uh the continuance of great depression
from 32 to 33 it was about five and a
half months market dropped 41 percent
the usd off gold standard watergate opec
all that combined it was about 21 months
market dropped 48 number three ready
great recession this is just 15 years
ago folks this is what you need to be
looking at this is literally 13 years
ago if you think about it 13 to 15 years
ago 0709 it was 17 months the market
dropped 54.1 percent some of you guys
are too young to say who's lehman
brothers but some of you guys are my age
you're 40 plus and you're like lehmann's
brothers was like lemons brothers they
went out of business do you remember
countrywide they went out of business do
you remember wamu it's a 330 billion
dollar company chase spawner for 1.9
they went out of business
merrill lynch was bought up by bank of
america now they still say merrill lynch
but it's a bank of america company
a lot of these companies are going to be
going through it as well no one in a
million years thought limas is going to
go out of business until they did
countrywide oh my god mozella used to
walk around he was the guy everybody
respected him they went out of business
companies that nobody thought was going
to go out of business they went out of
business during this time
uh new deal programs were cut and tax
increased march 6 uh 1937 238 this
lasted 13 months market dropped 55 and
the worst market crash you already knew
this from 1929 to 1932 lasted 34 months
market dropped 89.2 look at the picture
there he says 100 will buy this car must
have cash lost all on the stock market
how many people have played aggressive
with their money the last two years you
can answer this better than i can it's a
lot of people a lot of people have so
something's going to happen here now the
part that we have to look at is a lot of
time when we see this all we see there's
is negative scary but you know you're
scaring people pat no i'm not trying to
scare them just telling you what comes
after this but you have to be prepared
for this this is reality
right afterwards after world war ii look
how long economic expansion lasted 81
months
that's seven years nearly
it lasted
vietnam war era ended
economic expansion 108
months how much wealth do you think was
made during that time reaganomics cold
war reaganomics cold war afterwards
economic expansion 93
months the tech bubble
112 months afterwards u.s housing bubble
74 months covet pandemic 128 months is
economic expansion before those crisis
took place this is a long time the 128
months is the record by the way post
pandemic 24 months is still going today
so these things if you if you are able
to weather the storm the next six to 24
months and you do it properly
right afterwards what history tells us
is economic expansions around the corner
and that's when all of a sudden we hear
the next success stories of people who
did it the right way of p like buffett
has done this so many times in his
career and he knows what season this is
and everybody was criticizing him on
sitting on cash last year and now
buffett's going to be able to buy a lot
of stocks on sale because he's got
access to a lot of capital a lot of cash
so ge got started in 1908 this is what
happens during market crashes and
recessions they got started during a
recession hp heal packard during war
world war ii recession hyatt recession
microsoft recession uber airbnb a lot of
these companies slack again recession so
as as scary as it may be
some of you that are watching this you
taking notes and you're getting excited
not in a negative way but a positive to
say okay i want to go and make this my
season for my family i want to go light
it up perfect this is your season this
is your time to go out there and
capitalize with what's going on so why
are recessions a good time to start a
business less competition
all-in mentality access to talent talent
as prices a real market value better
rates rent vendors etc and by the way
let's this is just you and i talking
nobody else is around it's just me and
you right here talking
tell me you've worked very hard the last
two and a half years
the last two years have not been the
hardest working years of american
workers we've not worked that hard many
have worked from home
many like a couple seasons you stayed
home and you got stimulus some of you
that were working because you saw an
opportunity but the last two years
america got lazier okay
and because employers were afraid to
impose and challenge too much because
they were losing people anytime that
happens like oh my god don't push him
too hard he wants to take freight off
let him take friday off he wants to take
the week off and want to pto and he
doesn't want to do pto still wants to
work from home on his vacation let him
do it let him do it let him do it yeah
the standards and the fears of the
leaders has caused people to be lazy the
last two years but guess what the next
two years leaders are gonna have
backbone because market's gonna be on
their side okay so you're gonna see the
next two years the workers are going to
win but if you don't work the next two
years you're going to be exposed the
next two years maybe you got away with
it the last two years you can't get away
with it the next two years everyone in
the marketplace is going to have their
camera on you all eyes on you so meaning
if you do it right they're going to say
salute you're a winner if you don't do
it right they're going to say well
listen we got to kind of let you go and
move on it's not a message people want
to hear but it's just the reality of it
so eight eight ways to prepare for a
market crash number one anticipation we
talked about it earlier number two risk
tolerance have a sit down with you and
your wife or your husband or your family
and say what is my risk tolerance at
what level am i willing to risk a little
bit because
this is a season that if you're able to
manage your risk properly you can really
come out stronger afterwards but don't
make any moves if you can't tolerate
risk based on your age based on your
tolerance period like yours you may say
i'm not the kind of guy that likes us
and don't don't play around if it's not
part of your dna but if you manage your
risk properly the next six 12 24 months
you're gonna come out and uh you ought
to come out in a good place right
afterwards okay number three carry cash
cash is king everybody says cash is
trash cash is this and nobody's saying
cash is trash right now because if you
got cash things are going to be on sale
just so you know that so while you know
the dollar if you would have kept it it
would have lost eight percent okay fine
let's just say lost eight percent these
stocks lost 40 the last five months
a lot of things are going to be on sale
and as low as they are i believe it's
going to go lower but if you have cash a
lot of opportunities are going to come
up now i'm not telling you 100 cash you
don't want to be 100 historically it
doesn't benefit to be 100 cash because
nobody can time perfectly how the
market's going to do but it is a benefit
for people who can go out there and use
money to buy things on sale today many
have been preparing for this season to
come cash will be king the next 24
months cash was knocking the last 24
months cash will be king the next 24
months avoid any major real estate deals
unless if you're going to be living in
this house for 10 years if you can avoid
buying a house the next six to 12 months
i would do so uh uh if you can if again
if you're going to live in it great if
you're not going to live in it hold off
a little bit you're probably going to
buy it at a discounted rate six to 12
months from now have a serious business
plan in place
five percent precious metals um
this may be a season where the people
that are pro gold people will have an
argument oh yeah i told you gold has
done this yeah there may be right gold
may hit 2500 so you may want to have a
little bit of maybe two to five percent
precious metals and some of the crypto
is going to probably recover but you
know the precious metals may be
something for you to look at protect
your career what i mean by protecting
your careers or following
whatever you're doing right now recreate
yourself today
last two years
if you really improved nobody noticed
last two years if you read a lot of
books and you were the person that's
sitting there taking courses and getting
better and going to things events and
conferences nobody noticed nobody
noticed because people who didn't do
that made money so the market said oh
wow look how smart that guy is
but you were working on yourself nobody
noticed
but today
if you work on yourself to recreate
yourself in your company with the way
you show up with your attitude with
being a person that's showing up leading
working hard improving challenging your
peers setting the right example
constantly getting better reading
bringing new ideas bringing strategies
everyone's going to take notice the next
two years this is your season the people
that are in that mode of wanting to
improve themselves the next two years
are your season the last two years were
not your season just so you know number
eight take a time out and study your
portfolio good time to do that uh 10
steps to make millions during the market
crash number one monetize fear there's a
lot of people that are afraid what does
this mean to you
people who wouldn't take a meeting with
you a year and a half ago they're going
to take the meeting with you
we announced the zoom uh uh that i was
doing this market crash and everything
i'm doing with the powerpoint was on a
private zoom private webinar that i did
you know how it was so we said yeah
we're gonna get a few thousand people
like this
we're getting complaints on instagram
i'm trying to get on i'm trying to get
i'm trying yeah because the whole thing
was take thousands of people were on
for an hour and a half
and afterwards tens of thousands of
people signed on to want to see it they
keep wanting to see this they're asking
each other where is this where is that
where is this can i get a pre-crown i
miss this i miss that i'm you know why
because people are wanting to listen
today
because they're afraid
this message a year ago no one was
afraid everyone's bitcoin was at 69 000.
everyone's stock was killing it
everyone's portfolio was awesome
everyone's real estate portfolio was
awesome nobody was afraid people are
willing to listen and those who are able
to win at the highest level are able to
monetize fear i'm a parent of four you
know when my kids listen to me and i can
help them improve when they're a little
bit afraid
when they're cocky and they're not
afraid they don't listen when they're a
little bit afraid i can't give counsel
they'll receive it you were like that
i'm like that it's called human nature
understand this concept where how fear
works number two the lazy arrogant over
leverage will be filtered out it's
unfortunate so maybe you're watching
this right now you don't like this
comment i'm making you're going to be
filtered out i hope you're ready for it
so which means it's not too late to
change start working be humble and stop
being over leveraged okay because winter
is coming go you have it's not too late
to shift but those of you that stay lazy
arrogant on over leverage it's gonna be
a bad season for you next two years
become bankable meaning
if you say you're gonna do something do
it
if you're going to say you're going to
get on the zoom if you say you're going
to go do a meeting if you say you're
going to come through on a deadline a
number a commitment do it
the market
is currently
desperately
looking for leaders and people who say
what they're going to do
period
who say they're going to do what they're
going to do you do that the market is
going to want to work with you because
it's lacking right now people like that
number four strengthen numbers
um
join a community like right now wonder
that we launched our new website today
vitamin.com we've been working on this
for a while because everyone's asking
community community community so we have
a few different tiers so we have a
private social network that we just
announced where valuetainers from around
the world who work together regularly if
you don't see them if you go to the
vault conference you know what i'm
talking about but if you're not there's
a social network we launched just for
valentine's that they can talk to each
other what strategy are you using how
are you doing with this can i get a
referral for accountant what are you
using with lawyers how you guys handling
what do you think about real estate
thing how are you guys handling the
creating content what are you doing with
this gunshot com podcast what do you
guys think about this thumbnail that
community join a community if it's not
ours go join a community
join community because strength in
numbers is when you're going through a
season like this it's going to help you
if there's other people that are also
going through it where their strategies
becomes your strategy your strategy
that's working becomes their strategy
join any community of winners today
don't be doing this as a loner this is a
wrong time to be a loner this is a wrong
time to do this all by yourself you're
not going to win trying to do this by
yourself you need to be part of a
community we're going to put the link
below for the vitamin community you'll
find out how to be a part of that but
anyways if it's not ours go join a
community i believe our community's the
best because they're fun they're smart
they're intelligent they like to work
together and they're winners so if you
want to be around environment like that
that's our community that's valuetainers
if that's you you may want to join our
community valuetainer so strengthen
numbers number five and by the way part
would strengthen numbers for me would be
last night i'm having a cigar with matt
and mario at the house in a backyard
we're having a cigar we're watching the
games like midnight 11 30 and you know
boston came back anyways we're having a
conversation together
and
matt's like a pat so what are you
thinking about right now when you're
talking about adding the next zero
what's at the top of it where are
shooters having dinner as well yes that
converse question and the conversation
continue to the house i said one thing
he said what i said recruiting what do
you mean i said i'm i'm in the game of
recruiting because i believe in strength
in numbers
recruiting talent recruiting sales
recruiting investors recruiting
uh editors i'm recruiting salespeople
i'm recruiting executive c suites
hardcore executives middle management
i'm recruiting the talent to start their
podcast here with valuetainment i'm
recruiting
c-suites on my insurance company i'm
recruiting all i'm doing is recruiting
because anytime you want to upgrade like
when i was single you're recruiting a
spouse if you're single you're
recruiting friends you're recruiting
running mates you're recruiting
strengthen numbers is about recruiting
all of that so you need to be in the
right community to be able to recruit
the right kinds of people create a cause
your company can really get behind
you know when i first got involved in
insurance it was kind of like yeah you
know i'm just selling insurance so it's
more here oh money there's a lot of
money in insurance you know i'm a 22
year old guy 21 year old guy so what are
you thinking about oh money and all this
stuff right
and then all of a sudden i start making
money
and i started get the nice things that
comes with my travel in the world i'm
going to 30 plus countries and i'm still
28 years old i'm in all these different
places oh my god i can't believe i've
experienced this okay cool
and then all of a sudden it hits me i'm
like okay now you got some money in the
bank
now you got a girl you're dating that
you wanted to date
now you've traveled the world now you've
spoken in front of hundreds of thousands
of people
uh your dad's told you he's proud of you
your mom's told you she's proud of you
you've heard the magical words now what
because it was all logic logically i was
good
emotionally i wanted fire
i wanted fire
i wanted to see fire in my eyes all i
saw was logic so i started trying to
recruit the fire
in 08 was a very weird year for me
men when our age switches
that nine is the scariest number in
man's age sometimes a woman is well but
more men meaning
19 scary because you're about to be 20.
29 scared cause you're about to be 30.
29 39 you're about to be 40. you know
someone
i was 29 in a weight and man i was like
right here i'm like going crazy
but i wanted to find something here
so i finally went and found my cause
and in july of 15 i was dressed as a
george washington my wife was dressed as
lady liberty liberty i put an event
again in palm desert and i got up and i
said we'll be saving america by bringing
back the free enterprise system and hope
to american families capitalism caught
my heart
because it allowed an average guy i'm a
regular guy i don't have a four year or
two year i got a regular guy like me who
almost went and did 20 years in the
military because i didn't see a way out
my life changed because of capitalism i
got the opportunity to compete with
everybody else it was the ultimate great
equalizer
and that allowed me to have my dad live
in another 20 years my dad just
celebrated his 80th birthday he had a
heart attack at 44 years old while he
was in the waiting room and his mother
was in the hospital getting her heart
checked out he has not 44 this was 1993
1994 he's in the waiting room he
collapses they do an open heart surgery
you mean to tell me god gave me 10 more
years of my dad in my life
you mean to tell me i got 15 more years
my dad he's 80 years old today my kids
have a relationship with them i mean
that's that's where this fire comes from
you got to find your fire this moved me
i fell in love what america did to this
guy i've lived in iran i've lived in
germany i've lived in a lot of different
places i fell in love and i want to
share this passion with the world okay
so i come from a different place and it
happened in 08 during a recession look
at the timing
my wife would be next to me in the car
she was my girlfriend at the time she's
like what is up with this guy man you're
like so
pissed off sometimes you're like what's
going on with you i'm trying to recruit
my cause for the rest of my life and i
got it and it's been lit since oh wait
it's been 14 years now
you got to go recruit your cause today
don't take this slightly i don't know
what your cause is but go find your
calls today a cause
that makes you responsible leader to
perform not a cause that makes you it's
unfair it's a victim it's because of
this they don't see me i don't care
about that stuff i'm middle eastern and
i started this business and right after
9 11. what happened to 9 11. who did
everybody look at middle easterns what
do i look like i'm middle eastern so
imagine how many i went on an
appointment one time my husband and wife
says so can i ask you where you're from
sir
i said i'm from iran born and raised in
iran and i'm saying it proudly um we
appreciate you being on our i'll never
forget this appointment we appreciate
you being in our house
and coming out here but this may sound
awkward and we hope you take it
respectfully yes yes i'm 23 years old
can you send somebody else to us we're a
little bit uncomfortable doing business
with somebody from iran
i didn't walk away and cry about it i
walked when i said interesting well i
can't blame him look what just happened
right there
i can't blame him first place they go is
they think about somebody like that
great i sent somebody else to the
business with us but i didn't sell it i
got the split commission on it
i didn't go and cry to my mommy and my
daddy i'm a leader
you're a leader so whatever you cause
come you come out with make sure it's a
cause about you leading next cut the fat
cut the fat with friends
cut the fat with negative peers cut the
fat with employees co-workers who you
have lunch with that every time you go
and have lunch with these guys they
[ __ ] and you come back having an
argument with your boss your boss didn't
do anything wrong the people you had
lunch with the did things wrong
they imposed the hate in your boss that
you came back and had a fight with your
boss that you actually get along with
okay the friends that you don't have
arguments with your girlfriend or your
boyfriend or your husband or your wife
your friend who's so negative because
all he [ __ ] about it is his wife or
their husband and that energy came to
you and you came home that night and you
fought your wife or your husband cut the
fat
get rid of that person
cut the fat and move on with that person
okay you got to do this at this time
find your running mates double down on
positive distractions in your life today
positive distraction could be reading
the right books watching the right
documentaries being in the right
community hanging out and networking
with the right killers people that are
doing big things killers to me are
people that are after it in the hunt
they're chasing something right these
are people that are going a place be
around them let them be your positive
distraction in your life equip your team
with all possible audibles if this
happens we're gonna do this if that
happens we're going to do this but if
this happens we're going to do this
first then this then this then this and
to prepare all of this we're going to
buy this software we're going to hire
this person and we're going to invest
into this that's how you prepare and
call audibles and equip all your team
for that last but not least number 10
increase your level of urgency don't
move slowly move asap number one last
piece of advice i'll give you before we
wrap up here
as we're going through this so
um
i said this earlier when i said strength
in numbers
don't do this alone
go find a community i'm a byproduct of
that
i was fortunate enough to be in a good
community in the army i'm still friends
with those guys till today i was good
for them they were good for me
many of them became one and one at the
highest level in a different field
because we were part of a strong
community their strength in numbers okay
while you're going through this don't do
this alone have this video watch it with
your husband and your wife if you're
married don't make these decisions but
i'll ask your wife babe can you watch us
with me
honey watch this with me
have your running mates people that are
your business partners watch this
together what's our strategy next moving
for what do we want to do moving forward
what is my game plan when i went through
this i'm like i'm going to this
conference i'm attending this i'm going
to that it's 2014 2015 i'm clueless what
it is to be a ceo i'm a great sales
person i'm a great sales leader i'm a
great leader but i'm not a ceo i don't
know what it was to be a ceo what do i
do i spend 49 000 i go to a harvard or
owner president management program i
can't tell you anything i remember from
what the instructor said but i remember
vividly the guy sat next to me was the
ceo and the founder of the lingerie
company the victoria secret of new
zealand and australia he had six
thousand employees seven seals that
reported to him some number like that
and all he did is coach me on how to be
a ceo those three weeks that 49 thousand
dollars was 450 million dollars for me
on what i made i didn't want to go
through by myself i was in a room of 144
other c-suites ceos and founders from 64
different countries we were together
there's a community get around a
community of people to learn how to do
this with them there are mistakes
they're going to share with you don't do
this here's what i went through it so
don't try to go through this by yourself
and i will say just like the story i
told when i went from 100 000 to a
million dollars or 10 million 200
million to all this stuff
let this be the beginning season where
you're going to be sharing this story
with others as well there's a lot of
people doing it there's nothing special
about me there's many people like me out
there by the way many people like me out
there that are winning
why not you when he got this level why
not you making a decision today you
could be watching this on the toilet you
could be in the car right now listen to
this you could be in the living room
watching it for a second third time you
could be anywhere right now watching the
saying this is my season i'm going
and then go light it up
just stop trying to do it as a loner all
by yourself find the community find the
right running mate so a couple things i
want to wrap up with number one
uh join the vitamin community that we
have uh to be part of the vitamin
community we'll put the link below
whatever it's gonna be it's gonna be on
vitamin.com to go work with
our community by the way
today's powerpoint that i just gave you
i don't know how many slides it is oh
it's 60 slides if you want to get the
slides uh we'll give it to you for free
click on the link below to go subscribe
to our newsletter to uh
get started and you can do that and
we'll give it to you for free on the the
pdf or the powerpoint and if you want to
join our community you'll see the
different options to join the vitamin
community as well but i can't wait to
hear your stories about this i can't
wait to hear your success stories about
this i can't wait to hear from you
directly in our community there's
private webinars that i do in our
community i can't wait to hear more
feedback about what your biggest
takeaway from this video was and if it
was extremely valuable to you after you
watch this video share this video with
somebody else give us a subscribe button
give us a thumbs up and share this with
somebody else but whatever you do during
this season make sure you take massive
action because god knows the next 6 12
24 months definitely demand that type of
action take everybody bye bye bye bye
[Music]